[Musik]
herzlich kommt sondern wieder leute ich
hoffe es geht euch gut ich hoffe ihr
macht the basics nach wie vor ich bin
heute wieder für euch am start mit einem
neuen video und zwar werden uns heute
ein video von einer sehr qualifizierten
deutschen ärzteserie einziehen die rede
ist von der immer höchst realistischen
produktion wenig am kloot rengers warten
vor zwei monaten ein video auch beweisen
was ich mir heute aufgefallen ist das
heißt kopfhörer verschluckt wieso hat
kim ihren airport im bauch und da bin
ich mir sicher leute das hier bei einem
so realistischen medizinischen notfall
einiges zu sehen haben jetzt glaubt die
18-jährige kim sondern nach einem
fahrradsturz das bett hüten doch an
diese anweisung hält sich die junge frau
nicht okay also wir sehen ob es sich bei
diesem akuten medizinischen nun
verhandelt es ist die 18 jährige kim die
hier scheinbar einen bluetooth kopfhörer
im bauch haben soll
naja vielleicht ganz kurz ein echter
noch heute war immer wieder leute fragen
warum ich die videos so schnell stoppen
das macht nicht weil ich den nicht auch
länger laufen lassen würde sondern
einfach weil man die so schnell stopp
muss binnen nur eine gewisse länge auf
youtube zeigen darf weil sonst eben mehr
direkt hochgeladen werden können
nur damit ihr wisst ja ich bin
eingeschlafen
dann habe ich ihn einfach installiert ja
habe ich mir nichts dabei gedacht dachte
ich bin zwar hier mit dem kanal und
gebrochenen beinen wegen dem unfall aber
fällt mir jetzt schwer sogar beim
bullshit erklärung für zu finden wie gut
ist sie denn darauf
ja ich möchte da nicht verschluckt wie
kommst du auf die idee dass du den
kopfhörer verschluckt hast als erste
erklärung nachdem der kopfhörer weg ist
das habe ich in meinem leben noch nie
gehört dass jemand irgendeine sache
sucht und sondern sogar 50 sagt ja also
die fernbedienung habe ich jetzt nicht
unterm sofa gefunden hab ich wohl
verschluckt
und warum ist sie so gut drauf hast du
ja auch mal interessant zu sehen ob die
die ortungsfunktion von airports
funktioniert und man den bauch hat es
eine frage die ich mir vor beginn dieses
videos nicht gestellt habe die ich
befürchte dass jetzt trotzdem
beantwortet wird können auch in der
stelle mal darüber reden was sie hier
für eine party machen wir jetzt einfach
eingegipst das bein und kannst du durch
durch die ihr zimmer und erzählt freudig
dass sie ihren airport wahrscheinlich
inhaliert hat ja also ich weiß nicht ob
man der geschichte glauben schenken kann
würde würde das funktionieren wenn man
so ein ding verschluckt dass da
tatsächlich im bau figuriert und aber
die vibrieren und vibrierende airports
immer die ortet ich habe selbst airports
aber machen die nicht einfach nur ein
piepton wieso freut sie sich sowieso
nicht so als hätte jemand gesagt dass
sie schwanger ist nach fünf jahren in
dem sie versucht schwanger zu werden und
sie das hat nicht geklappt jetzt aber
mal geklappt so ist dass das kürzel
nicht egal es ist wirklich so dass ich
schwanger einfach mit dem einzigen
unterschied dass elektrotechnik in ihrem
bauch drin ist aber sie freute sich gut
drauf war sehr schon von anfang an hat
er schon von anfang an die theorie den
raum gerufen sogar ich glaub ich hab die
verschluckt
es ist wirklich eins zu eins einfach
eine überraschende schwangerschaft die
man aber sich gewünscht hat das 190
direktion finde ich persönlich gesagt
nicht nicht gesund genial ist auch die
beschreibung bei diesem video kim hört
im bett musik und schläft ein dabei
verschluckt sie ihre kabellosen
kopfhörer wieso hat die 18-jährige den
airport im bauch da muss ich wirklich
sagen stellt sich am kloot ring genau
die richtigen fragen wieso hat man dinge
die man verschluckt hat danach im bauch
wie kann ich will ich bin ein bisschen
ratlos ehrlich gesagt leute ich bin auch
wirklich gespannt wie die erklärung von
senica bringen sein wird dass sie das
ding jetzt irgendwie wieder richtig
hinbiegen und plausibel erklären warum
ist ihr ein airport verschluckt
verzichten das erscheint mir erstmal
unrealistisch ja meine rede ein
gegenstand verschluckt ist keine schöne
sache
schauen wir ihre reaktionen dazu noch
mal an sie sind zeitgleich glücklich und
hey aus oder
es war ein runder und glatter gegenstand
sie hat ihn wohl so im schlaf
runtergeschluckt hat er keine
beschwerden
sorry aber leute irgend jemand von euch
arbeitet doch im krankenhaus oder sind
wir auf irgend jemand von euch arbeitet
im krankenhaus erzählt mir bitte die von
euch die mit kollegen reden und der
arbeiten müssen mehr erfahrung haben ist
kann so was passieren ist so was
plausibel
die meisten gewesen dass so was mit dem
großen schlag passieren kann dass pacman
alter weil er wahrscheinlich auch so
schläft ja dann ist kann es wirklich
sein dass er einfach sich umdreht und
das ding einfach auftakt aber so ein
mensch glaube ich eher nicht eine halbe
stunde später ist die 18 jährige zurück
auf station und mit ihr die
röntgenbilder ihres bauchraums jetzt
kommt der arzt zur ernster miene musik
ja also wir haben werden die
röntgenbilder bekommen und so setzen sie
sich vielleicht erst mal in nächst
besseren sie sitzen
wir haben in ihrem bauch tatsächlich
fast gefunden und zwar müssen wir ihnen
mitteilen dass sie schwanger mit einem
fake airport sind ja ich habe schon
gesehen ja ich habe mich helferin beim
ultraschall röntgen blicks und durch
meinen bauch durchgeschaut deswegen habe
ich die die röntgenaufnahme stand
gesehen oder am main airport an sich den
hat sich natürlich auch nicht gesehen
weil sie hat ihn zwar benutzt und in der
echten welt draußen außerhalb ihres
magens lange gehabt aber sie hätten
nicht gesehen wirkt ja okay also an der
krümmungen hier erkennen wir dass ich
kann schon mal ausschließt es ist kein
amazon fake das ist kein amazon fällt
aber wenn wir jetzt hier mal genau unter
ihrem becken kam auf die ohrmuschel
schauen sehen wir die sie haben diesen
kopfhörer von risch bestellt sie sind
schwanger mit einem kopfhörer
aber das sieht ganz gut aus und ich
würde sagen das lassen wir einfach auf
natürlichem wege passieren und wenn sie
sauerkraut und das war ganz gut wäre
ja also wenn sie sauerkraut mögen wir
das ganz gut und wurde erst einmal so
also das hat keinerlei medizinische
gründe ist ich finde aber persönlich gut
wenn sie sauerkraut mögen
genau damit sie dann daran erstickt wenn
sie es nicht mal verschluckt das dann
auch entsprechend das kabel mit
runtergeschluckt wird weil schauen wir
dass ich ein mensch ist der kopfhörer
versteckt habe ja niemand leben gehört
aber es ist so dass kabel an hier
wirklich nachts dann auch am gaumen
dranhängt das heißt dann mitten in der
nacht aufwacht dass das dann sofort mit
dem extremem würgereiz und genau mit
atemnot auch dann ist es nämlich besser
man muss aber sagen dass schon eine
geile taktik von dem von dem personal
das sind sie nicht am kanal macht
einfach mal so normale folge gehabt ich
glaube da ging es irgendwie um einen
gutartigen tumor nun also auch ein
heikles thema so und dann klicken sie
einfach so ach nee nee nee nee das nicht
spannend genug dass man was man noch las
man noch jemanden main airport
verschlucken was ist das von den
reaktionen so wies auch darüber redet
dass sie operiert werden muss muss jetzt
operiert werden ich müsste mir jetzt
eventuell meinen kompletten bauch per
skalpell gewaltsam öffnen und meinen
elektronischen gegenstand der ein akku
und brandgefahr mit sich bringt in sich
trägt könnte es auch ohne narkose machen
einen kommentar weist noch darauf hin
deborah la douce das ist einfach nicht
mal airport sind okay
die sind angeblich von samsung galaxy
ports oder sonst jemand geschrieben an
den kommentar finde ich aber völlig
fahrlässig vom arzt oder eigentlich
sollte der arzt auf dem röntgenbild
erkennen dass es sich hier nicht um mord
handelt wie ursprünglich irrtümlich von
mir angenommen sondern um galaxy potts
wofür profil studierter denn aber doch
die frage ist wiederum könnte man knapp
abonnieren bleibt stabil bleibt an der
frage daran warum dinge die man
verschluckt hat im bauch landen wir sind
es bald wieder mit neuen video macht's
gut